Given everything that we know now,
let's review our current agreed upon and
de-normalized data schema design.
I've made some generic json to
map out what we've discussed for
the final data design.
And I went ahead and
I included it in the instructor notes.
Be careful about not overwriting
your database with it.
You can always make a new fire
base app back end if necessary.
To frame all of this, let's think about
the screens that we're interested in.
The two that we've been talking about
a lot are the shopping list fragment and
the active list detail screen.
And remember the goal is to allow
users to be able to create lists and
share lists.
And then they should only see the lists
that they either own or are shared on.
Okay, so
I'm going to load up the station and
open up our back and sort of walk
you through what's going on.
Here are our top level nodes.
Following our discussion of two
way mapping between users and
the list they own, I think the best way
to handle this sharing functionality
is to have a list of shopping lists for
each user.
Here, let me show you.
We're going to have this node
here called userLists, and
this will contain for each user a list
of the lists that they have access to.
That means if JP, myself and Walter
are all in the shoppinglist++ system.
Then there would be a separate list
of shopping lists for each of us.
And again these would be the list
that we either own or shared with us.
So in this case Walter has
one list shared with him.
And if he were to create or
be shared on with another list.
That would also appear here.
And this is actually pretty much all
of the information that we need for
the shopping list fragment.
You could go ahead and
attach your Firebase list adapter here
at the encoded email address
of the user who is logged in.
So if Walter is the one logged in,
then we could attach a listener here and
it would very easily display
the list that he owns.
Since we got the shopping
list fragment figured out.
Let's think about the active
list detail screen.
For the list detail screen
we'll need the list information
which we can grab here from
the list of user lists.
And we can get that because at that
point we should have the encoded email
of the user and
the push idea of the list.
And that gives us enough information
to drill down to the email.
And then the push ID to
get that list information.
And from here we could get things like
the user's shopping on the list and
the list name.
And then, as we've already been doing,
we de-normalized and
had the shopping list items up here.
And we can use that same
shopping list push ID
to get the shopping list items for
the list, as we've been doing.
Okay, so that explains the use
of both the user list and
the shopping list items.
Now at this point you're probably
thinking that this design has
a non-trivial amount of data copying.
Here each of us has our list
of lists in user lists.
And if we each make four
different lists and
we owed them this is
what it would look like.
But let's say that cougar A decides that
she wants to share her book club snacks
list with all of us.
What this would then do is add a copy of
book called snacks to each of our lists.
A total of three more copies.
Now this design here makes reading for
the database lightning fast.
We never have to search through
a list of all shopping lists, or
pull down any extra data.
But, you're probably thinking that
there must be some downside to all of
this copying.
Well, there is.
Whenever you change anything
about the shopping list,
such as to change the list
name to book club snacks.
You need to do this for
all copies of the shopping list.
So now instead of changing something in
just one place you need to change it in
four different places.
And more importantly
when you update a list,
you need a way to know quickly
if there are other copies of
that same list in the database without
any extra sorting or filtering.
For example if you're just looking at
this wilderness survival list here.
You have no way to know whether
it's been shared with other users.
And for
that we have a node called shared with.
Let's take a look at it in the database.
So here's shared with, let's notice
kind of like shopping list items.
For every list that is shared, you
will have an entry and share it with.
And the key of that note
will be the list push ID.
Inside of that node will be a list of
users that that shopping list has been
sharedWith.
So going back to our book club example,
when you want to update the value of
a list such as the list name, you
have one place where you can look up all
the users of the list to share it with.
This allows you to construct
the various URLs that you'll need
to get to the user list of the database.
Because now you have access to
everybody's encoded email, you have both
parts the encoded email and the push ID
that you need to get to a specific list.
Okay, so at this point we've talked
about sharedWith, shoppingListitems and
userLists.
We're going to keep
around our list of users,
which we'll just have all of
the users that are in our app.
And this is functioning
as it did before.
We'll also make some userFriends lists.
But I'll talk more about that when we
go into implementing those screens.
Okay, so if you want to take a look
at this database structure yourself,
you can load up the JSON file
with the instructor notes.
Once you have a handle
on what's changed and
what's sort of going on here,
we'll start the refactor from
the huge list of shopping lists that's
currently stored in the active list node
to this new user lists centric
organization that I've described.